federal officials are investigating a
devastating head-on crash between a bus
and a pickup truck in Texas 13 people
were killed yesterday when the pickup
slammed into the bus carrying church
members home from a retreat only one
person on the bus survived along with
the truck's driver the collision
happened west of San Antonio Omar
Villafranca is at the accident scene in
khon kaen texas omar good morning good
morning the roads down here in this part
of South Texas are two lanes narrow and
curvy the accident happened behind me
about 75 yards right there in the curve
there are still tire marks on the road
the lone survivor in the bus is in
critical condition the driver of the
truck is stable the church members were
coming back from a three-day retreat
when the horrific accident happened the
mangled wreckage is evidence of the
brutal force of the high-speed crash
police say the passenger bus was heading
southbound on highway 83 and the white
pickup truck was driving in the
northbound lane then the truck crossed
the double line hitting the bus head-on
there could have been many contributing
factors we just don't know yet we have
to give the investigators time to look
at everything and then we'll we'll know
exactly what happens the church group
had just left the alto Frio Baptist
encampment in leakey Texas when the
accident happened less than 10 miles
from the campsite police say at first
they did not realize just how tragic of
a wreck they were responding to we're
used to working fatal crash scenes but
first time that we've ever seen
something like this happened with so
many confirmed dead at one time in a
tweet Texas governor Greg Abbott offered
his condolences thank the first
responders who worked the scene and
asked all Texans to offer their thoughts
and prayers their families are going to
be hurting and our church families is
going to be hurting news of the crash
left members of the First Baptist Church
of New Braunfels shell-shocked people
could be seen walking away in tears
church pastor Brad McLane said their
faith is helping them cope with the
devastating loss
together we're just trying to be very
respectful of our families and provide a
place for our church family to come
together
to cry with each other you know to hug
each other pray with each other police
have not released any of the names of
anyone who died there will be grief
counselors at the First Baptist Church
of New Braunfels all week for anyone who
may need it Nora
all right Omar thank you so much